if you love Star Wars and you love Lego
then good news tt games is developing a
new Lego title based on Star Wars The
Force awakens seriously to those guys
ever sleep I'm Lucy and welcome to this
space soap opera gamespot news update a
game will bridge the gap between Star
Wars Episode six return of the jedi and
episode 7 the force awakens naturally
the iconic cast of characters from both
films will feature in the game and you
can play as rey finn home bb-8 kylo Ren
han Solo and all the rest of your
favorites the description reads lego
star wars the force awakens also
introduces multi build and blaster
battles to the Lego videogame universe
with multi builds use available Lego
bricks open up new parts and break them
apart and rebuild them again to open up
another during blaster battles use your
surroundings as cover to stand against
the first order the game will launch on
jun 28 and if there's not an emo kylo
Ren that I'm gonna riot so what do you
reckon we hit peak Star Wars or are you
excited for more play time with finn and
ray let me know in the comments box
below or come find me on twitter i'm
melissa james games for all the latest
galaxy goings-on make sure you keep it
gamespot